ja sind die denn alle besoffen manchmal
habe ich echt den Eindruck dass ich in
der Bundesregierung unabhängig von der
jeweiligen Koalition schwere Alkoholiker
und Alkoholikerinnen zusammen tun
jedenfalls wenn man sich die
Verkehrspolitik von Volker Wissing
ansieht aber der Reihe nach nur noch mal
zur Erinnerung der ehemalige
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Peter Altmaier
der scheint wahrscheinlich all die Jahre
gedacht zu haben sein Ministerium
kümmere sich um wirtschaften und nicht
um die Wirtschaft durch einen
Rechenfehler war der Infraschall von
Windrädern in seiner Behörde der
Bundesanstalt für Geowissenschaften und
Rohstoffe 64 mal lauter eingestuft
worden als er tatsächlich ist er musste
sich entschuldigen also mir passieren
solche Rechenfehler nur wenn ich
wirklich komplett knülle bin und knülle
scheint er wohl gerne mal zu sein
offenbar leicht angeschicker twitterte
er mal oder nennt man das jetzt Xen
gegen einen Achtung Böller
Verkaufsverbot und dieser Tweet war noch
voller weiterer Fehler apropos geschickt
hat unser Bundesverkehrsminister Volker
Wissing ist Winzer muss das sein kein
Alkohol am aber das
Bundesverkehrsministerium wird von einem
scheinbar weidenseligen Weinbauern
gesteuert und wer jetzt argumentiert das
Winzer nicht gleich betrunken sein
bedeutet der sollte mal bei einer
professionellen Weinprobe dabei sein da
wird so viel gebächert obwohl
ausgespuckt es ist eigentlich nicht
vermeidbar oder bei den Sitzungen des
parlamentarischen weinforums des
Deutschen Bundestages ja das gibt es
tatsächlich die treffen sich zum sich
hinter die Binde kippen ich will jetzt
absolut nichts unterstellen aber mal
Hand aufs Herz Alkohol wird in
Deutschland verharmlost und Cannabis
dramatisiert jedenfalls so wie Volker
Wissing Politik macht das erinnert er an
eine Alkoholfahrt als an
verantwortungsvolle Politik ach was
heißt verantwortungsvolle Politik
überhaupt an Politik tut mir jetzt ein
bisschen leid für den Freien Demokraten
sein Vorgänger Maut der Bakel andreas
Scheuer war ja nur bescheuert sorry für
den flachwitz wenigstens kümmert sich
Volker Wissing um die Deutsche
Bundesbahn und den öffentlichen Personen
nach Verkehr aber beim Auto heißt es ein
Mann sieht rot Verzeihung Gründen freie
Fahrt für freie Bürger auch wenn das
Navi des Bundesverkehrsministeriums da
die Klimaziele weit verfehlt als App
wäre das reinste short Software niemand
würde sie verwenden und die deutsche
Autoindustrie fährt er damit
Entschuldigung navigiert er damit an die
Wand gut gemeint ist halt nicht gleich
gut gemacht kein Tempolimit ist da nur
die Spitze des Eisbergs mehr Straßen
wieder bauen und stützt sich auf Studien
die mehr Verkehr Voraussagen wobei die
Realität einfach ganz anders aussieht
wir können ja kaum noch mehr fahren und
durch Corona Home Office und Deutschland
Ticket sind die Zahlen sowieso dauerhaft
nach unten gegangen aber im
Bundesverkehrsministerium scheinen
Fakten eher Faktoren zu sein
Störfaktoren liebe Grüße von Peter
Altmaier oh Mann und dann sagt er auch
noch solchen Schwachsinn wie nicht er
sei für die nicht Einhaltung der
Klimaziele verantwortlich sondern die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger die zu viel
Abgase ausstoßen würden das ist ja so
als würde man als Justizminister sagen
dass man nicht für die vielen Morde
zuständig sei sondern die Mörder nur
noch mal zu Erinnerung was Politik
eigentlich ist einer Gesellschaft
Rahmenbedingungen geben die das
Zusammenleben ermöglichen und die
Grundsätze dafür sind im Grundgesetz
festgeschrieben wie eben auch der
Klimaschutz durch den Anspruch auf
körperliche Unversehrtheit und wenn ein
Minister dann sagt dass die Täter
verantwortlich sein dann ist das
schlicht und einfach keine Politik
sondern Stammtisch für Phase und dann
werden wir dann wieder beim Wein und ich
würde mal sagen bei locker 1,5 Promille